relationship advice boys oh god we
helped so many people this is Tony from
Massachusetts Massachusetts what up
fellas Gang Gang buzz-buzz
yeah so I need some relationship advice
I've been seeing this girl recently
she's about 10 years older than me who
I've been in that way that's a stripper
well what'd he say amazing she's a great
girl she's been going to school like
long session the thing that makes me
nervous about her is she's really clingy
and I don't know if I'm just laying down
the pipe right or I'm someone she hasn't
met before it's really exciting it's
really fun it just she's a stripper
roaming she met so many biggest Brendan
wanting to be with me every night
wanting to sleep over Vava blah you know
you know how it goes nope
I'm sure my god I don't know let me know
what I should do about this situation
it's kind of tough for me to make a
judgment call on it
love you man bang I appreciate you
calling in doing this guy seem like a
nice guy was like something sounds like
some first dr. drew but yeah sure man
really yeah well here's the thing to do
yes stage-five clinger it's a stripper
you the only guy in her life that she
can trust clearly probably didn't have a
dad let's be honest you don't know do
they have a picture of the woman to have
a family portrait I thought we did we
don't well that's news to me
let's do more work everybody I think
that he should just SPECT her tragic
over there
- typing like like well we've narrowed
it down to everyone
um dude be grateful the chick wants to
chill with you all the time man and do
fun stuff what is this guy asking us I
couldn't figure I was trying to notate
what is being a what's being occurred so
he's dating an ex-stripper he's 25 she's
34 okay
she's clingy and bipolar but the sex is
amazing he just doesn't know what oh he
did say bipolar yeah he said she's
bipolar
oh you a doctor now - bro maybe she's
just Moody
maybe she's works late as [ __ ] like a
vampire so during the day she's a little
[ __ ] Brynn they're not insane what do
you mean that's insane
supers don't work during the day it's an
insane question or answer they do work
some of them do work during the day dude
no those who shout out to those ladies
who are hardworking strippers it's easy
to be in there stripping at night when
everybody's throwing money around you're
right you be in there in the daytime
when nobody's in there you're right
you're right it's like open mics you
know right shout out to all of those
daytime strippers bro you know them
sunshine twerkers babies I'm stripper
nation boy yeah yes in yeah you UV you
the ugly ducklings of the club and
that's why is there during the day
beautiful their hard work and they have
families that are lost no they're
usually busted and COS notice it's the
busted sunshine hoes and prime rib go
hand-in-hand trying to get people in so
you can have a little meat and watch
these uglies thank him Brendon that's a
shrimp club dude yeah but I see that I
think you got to see the beauty in all
of them it's not just about how there
are you guys Jamie come on down yeah
Jamie does her best he tries super hard
and she's a nice lady
you know she failed out of school but
who did and you know Jamie's learning to
knit and just filled up her car with gas
you know he's really nervous
Jamie's nervous [ __ ] it doesn't want to
be here it's your money everybody it's
1:15 p.m. on a Thursday it's 2:00 in the
afternoon she has a full [ __ ] outfit
on refused to take off her jeans
give it up for Jenny Shepard I'm talking
about me - was that represent yeah you
taint strip nervous yeah they're little
stiff up there you know I'm saying yeah
Ruthie's fantasy teams struggled this
past weekend she's really good at tough
time she had a goes for breakfast
Carey is on break from Home Depot but
you saved me a couple of bucks dude I
like those highlights that man to
emotional strippers really work in real
strippers yeah I go at night but I feel
you so what's this guy just basically
this guy was just telling us that he's
been doing good sex with a lady
basically let's go to cat let's get some
female or Sarah to her - Derek I mean
the stripper may look at him like he's
her future 401k like a retirement plan a
young guy doing well if he's doing I was
doing well or has potential to do well
he's younger maybe he's in a more stable
lifestyle than she is she just wants
someone to come home - dude you ever you
ever met some of those strippers side
zippers they're smart man where they get
all that cast they got properties and
[ __ ] but not all of them are
unfortunately and then they got their
real estate license and [ __ ] on the side
I got a damn thing about buying this
house you got that blowout ass girl yeah
you can catch me at diamond Cabaret
tonight
I'll take the crib look see a diamond
cabaret girl it's tough out there people
are doing their bad you know it's really
tough for a lot of these ladies out
there and uh you know if we if we can do
anything to help I guess just reach out
to us you know I feel like we're eight
my stripper dude they send in pictures
of Elsa am i doing all right you right
you right that'd be disgusting well I'm
just how bad a terrible you know I don't
need to do about what love could help
them or it blows them the [ __ ] up the
more dudes go and they make crazy money
and then they retire early and we're
helping one strip at a time stripper
thong nope that's a Spring Break dude
that's Andy dick [ __ ] brother some kind
of shitty Andy Dick does you know and I
sayin Cancun
look spitballing ideas here try to help
this kid out what does he need from us
this guy what was he asking us
relationship advice like about what like
specific down oh he's dating
stripper she's clingy bipolar he doesn't
know what to do should he stay with her
should he not stay with her I don't
think he's gonna be up to you brother to
be honest with you I I think she's
driving this ship yeah you go yeah I'm
the captain now look at my teeth yeah
that was not an impersonation huge and
he thought it was him
I did too I thought lose six hairs for
thinking about yourself what I'm saying
is this uh you're gonna be fine dude
okay
you're naked right now in this video you
don't have a [ __ ] shirt on you're in
bed if I can be man
you've obviously just be either
masturbated or recently calm clearly
sleep on a futon you're gonna be great
and this lady's gonna make the choice if
she's bipolar tri-polar you know that's
how they do it now
you know strippers next thing you know
she [ __ ] saws your arms off and they
find you two years from now and a
[ __ ] body bag outside of Gainesville
so I like when they're bipolar give you
a nice lap dance and maybe come up with
a business plan after yeah oh yeah
investing a few ideas okay so I think
yeah I wait for those flying cars Becky
I [ __ ] I think play it out maybe boy
yeah let's see how it goes bro yeah we
hope he helped you out and thank you for
reaching out to us man we appreciate the
support and I would like to picture a
next time and thanks for checking out
King in the sting too brother
yeah
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]